Jacob and just curious do you remember  the first time that you were recognized  when you you know this is this is a big  you coming into this big show what was  your first time you got recognized where  were you and what happened all right  yes I was on I was on the subway in New  York this was all really  it was season four so only season three  dead mm-hmm and I'm just sitting minding  my own business and where are you you're  I'm on the subway a subway okay I think  I was heading towards Times Square I  don't know if that's an important detail  [Applause]  yeah all of a sudden I just heard yeah a  great word  I had my head down my head was down and  it was like huh what what just happened  yeah that's up and nobody was looking at  me there was a guy there was a guy that  had a newspaper and it kind of it was  you you're not reading it yeah wait he  just quickly put up a newspaper that is  so away nobody or help me cut out the  eyes so if he could be  you